[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur france 3
bourgogne et france 3 franche comté pour
dimanche en politique c'est donc une
première sous la vème république
françois hollande ne briguera pas un
second mandat à l'elysée alors après
hollande le renouveau ou le cas où pour
le parti socialiste et la gauche c'est
la question qu'on va se poser avec nos
trois invités élus de bourgogne franche
comté sur ce plateau mots de classe
qu'un vice présidente du conseil
régional première fédéral du parti
socialiste dans le territoire de belfort
face avoue françois patriat sénateur
socialiste de côte-d'or partisan d'
emmanuel macron et puis céline maglica
conseillère départementale socialiste de
côte-d'or et soutient vous d'arnaud
montebourg bonjour à tous les trois
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous le savez cette émission c'est aussi
la vôtre vous pouvez interpeller nos
invités leur faire part de vos
commentaires de vos questions sur la
page internet de l'émission sur les
sites de france 3 bourgogne et france 3
franche comté et puis vous pouvez aussi
commenter l'émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le mode yade qui s'affiche
dit mme paul bfc comme dimanche en
politique bourgogne franche comté
c'est simple et je me ferai le relais de
vos questions tout au long de cette
émission
alors mesdames monsieur d'abord l'image
politique de la semaine
vive la république et vive la france
mode claf qu'un françois hollande ne
sera donc pas candidat à un second
mandat comment vous avez réagi à cette
annonce
ce fut indéniablement une surprise pour
moi mais je pense qu'il a fait un choix
en conscience
il a fait un choix courageux un choix
digne et dans la façon de l'exprimer
également il ya eu beaucoup d'émotions
pendant cette cette allocution du
président hollande mais je pense qu'il a
tenu compte de sa cote de popularité est
évidemment de la situation à gauche
l'enjeu étant évidemment aujourd'hui de
rassembler le plus largement possible
notre famille politique et il a pris je
pense la décision qui s'imposait céline
maglica surprise aussi surprise pas tant
que ça en quelque sorte parce qu'on
voyait bien dont les rencontres qu'on
peut faire avec nos concitoyens que
l'impopularité elle était très forte de
françois hollande
moi j'allais dire que je suis
agréablement surprise si je le puis dire
comme ça parce que je crois que c'est
une décision effectivement qui est
extrêmement lucide extrêmement lucide et
effectivement qui a été fait avec avec
élégance avec dignité et qui est un
geste nouveau finalement dans l'histoire
de nos institutions un président qui
décide en conscience de ne pas y
retourner parce qu'il a conscience de ne
pas être la bonne personne au bon moment
pour porter les valeurs de la gauche
donc je salue cette décision et je pense
que c'est un réel espoir pour nous
aujourd'hui un espoir aussi françois
patriat pour vous c'est la décision qui
centrait courage lucidité
les mots étaient repris je les reprends
mon nous autour d'emmanuel macron nous
pensions depuis plusieurs mois même
depuis plus d'un an que françois
hollande ne serait pas en situation de
pouvoir se présente c'est le pari que
vous avez fait effectivement le fait
c'est pour ça que nous avons construit
ce mouvement avec les appartenances de
chacun depuis des mois et des mois qui
aujourd'hui à plus de 110 mille
adhérents et nous l'avons fait pensant
qu'il fallait préparer avant cette
élection dont l'échéance est bien celle
du mois d'avril du mois de mai de la
préparer en respectant le chef de l'état
que nous n'avons d'ailleurs je n'ai
jamais critiqué
on va y revenir françois patriat mais
d'abord les mots qui reviennent c'est
lucidité courage il y en a un autre une
réaction de données
nous les envoyer pendant la semaine
françois hollande aurait dû démissionner
bien avant car il n'a pas la carrure et
le sait très bien quel gâchis gâchis
c'est aussi le mot employé par
marie-guite dufay la présidente
socialiste du conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté qui dit elle
elle a plutôt elle tire un bon bilan
plutôt positif elle dit j'ai le
sentiment d'un immense gâchis aussi
parce que quelque part c'est un aveu
d'échec l'ensemble de son action ne
méritait pas cet aveu d'échec ce qui
salue françois hollande ceux qu'ils
critiquent ont tous ce mot à la bouche
vous êtes d'accord c'était un gars c'est
un gâchis
céline maglica moi je non je
n'utiliserai pas ce terme là je ne crois
pas que ce soit un gâchis françois
hollande n'aurait pas dû démissionner
françois hollande aurait dû y a pas les
légionnaires non mais par rapport à la
la la citation que vous ne faisiez
précédemment de l'auditeur françois
hollande aurait dû tenir compte
davantage de ce qu'un certain nombre de
militants du parti socialiste et d'élus
autour de lui lui disait il c'est un
moment donné coupé du discours du
bourget et des ambitions qu'il avait eu
à ce moment là il n'a pas su écouter je
pense évidemment à arnaud montebourg qui
a essayé au sein du gouvernement pendant
deux ans de réorienter la politique
économique en proposant un autre chemin
il n'a pas été entendu et donc je pense
que françois hollande aurait dû écouter
davantage nos positions en ce domaine
plutôt que de considérer à la fin que
c'est un gâchis
bob clark à moi je partage l'avis de
mardi du fait je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons à faire un énorme gâchis
parce que françois hollande et
l'ensemble du gouvernement
durant ce quinquennat on fait pour
partie en tout cas ce qu'ils avaient dit
qu'il ferait je pense simplement qu'il
ya eu deux erreurs majeures
la première c'est de ne pas avoir
expliqué de façon très concrète quand il
est arrivé au pouvoir
l'état du pays dans lequel l'habitant
mais il mais c'est important
il était important de préciser très
clairement les choses qui n'a pas
forcément été suffisamment fait et
d'autre part je pense qu'un certain
nombre de réformes qu'il a engagées
pendant ce quinquennat n'a pas
suffisamment été expliqué il n'y a pas
été suffisamment de communication sur
ces réformes là est évidemment
deux erreurs qui l'a clairement fait
qu'ils sont la déchéance de nationalité
et la version une de la loi travail
alors justement on a demandé aux
bisontins et auditionné vendredi ce
qu'il pensait de cette annonce de
françois hollande
propos recueillis par chloé thibault et
sophie à nice et wii puis vous réagissez
juste je pense que c'est en est bien
tiré en beauté c'est très bien c'est une
décision fort intelligente et ça ne
modifie en rien l'opinion que j'avais de
lui à savoir que je trouve malgré tout
ce qu'on dit sur lui que c'est un homme
bien
je pense qu'il a un bilan qui est pas
très positif donc c'était courageux de
sa part de faire son mea culpa
j'espérais qu'il allait dire ça on a eu
beaucoup de faux espoirs et c'est un peu
dommage je voyais pas comment il peut
aussi représenter avec ban devant les
électeurs avec un tel bilan club le
quinquennat se termine comme il a
commencé c'est-à-dire sur une erreur de
casting c'est tout qui pourrait
représenter la gauche alors aujourd'hui
manuel valls peut-être manuel valls
j'espère que ça serait mal et va
peut-être valls peut-être nous monsieur
macron à parme ac on n'y a pas beaucoup
de nouveautés
j'ai tous les mêmes c'est des libéraux
c'est tout quand on prendra le fric où
il faut prendre le fric chez les riches
et qu'on donnera au pot le fric yaya
qu'à partager c'est tout voilà
voilà tous les mêmes pour cette
bisontine françois patriat qui peut
rassembler la gauche aujourd'hui
alors d'abord répondre à la question
vous est posée avant je faisais pas être
que répondre moi-même je n'en sors le
garder au gâchis pas le mot gâchis parce
que je pense qu'il ya dedans qui a dans
ce quinquennat les choses très positives
et notamment très positif comme des
avancées à gauche qui seront salués pour
l'avenir mais je pense surtout que je
pense que emmanuel je pense que les
violences et que vous soyez là à penser
à cela des a été victime de la primaire
de 2012
c'est dans ton à l'instant ça qui est
intéressant parce que dans la primaire
aujourd'hui qui est lente reçoit des
partis politiques pour aider pour être
élu il faut arriver à avoir des
compromis et voir les compromissions et
il s'est avéré que les dissensions qui
avait eu lors de la primaire aurait
surgi après doux sons et les frondeurs
doux sonder les oppositions au chef de
l'état qui n'a pas pu surmonter
en fin de compte françois hollande est
victime de son propre clan la foster's a
lancé leur ordinaire de dominer la
prévert de 2000 exactement poule à il ya
eu entre martine aubry et françois
hollande
la fracture qui a été faussement
refermer lors de l'élection s'est
ouverte aussitôt après avec une majorité
qui n'a pas suivi intégralement le
président ça veut dire que vous êtes
totalement d'accord avec ce qu'a dit le
premier ministre il y a quelques
semaines les gauches sont
irréconciliables je le pense réellement
je pense c'est pas seulement ça sic
l'union de la gauche telle qu'elle a
vécu depuis françois mitterrand qu'elle
a vécu après celui annales jospin
qu'elle a vécu encore avec françois lent
et s'étale en une la gauche elle est
morte aujourd'hui il ya des gauches
irréconciliables
vous ne ferez jamais revenir mélenchon
et le pc je le vois au sénat chaque jour
dans une union de la gauche et vous ne
le ferez parvenir
est ce parce que ces gens là analyse la
situation avec comme l acte et au siècle
dernier avec des propositions du siècle
dernier
il faut aujourd'hui renverser la table
changer les choses
c'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas compris on
voudrait nous remettre dans le même
schéma aujourd'hui avec des guerres de
clans du des guerres claniques avec lens
reçoit des parties ce dont les français
ne veulent plus céline maglica sept
candidats aux primaires à gauche sept
candidats à l'intérieur de la primaire
sans compter une éventuelle candidature
de manuel valls que beaucoup attendent
dans les tout prochains jours
ça ressemble à quoi alors d'abord moi je
voudrais répondre à ce qui vient d'être
dit première monde gagne pas sur un
bilan on le sait depuis jospin on ne
gagne pas sur un bilan même s'il ya
effectivement des avancées qui ont été
effectués par françois hollande et je le
reconnais y des choses très bien
de fait mais on ne gagne pas sur un
bilan on ne gagne pas sur un bilan
encore moins quand il est mitigé comme
celui de françois hollande
la deuxième chose c'est que je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse mettre le problème sur
les primaires les primaires on doit
simplement trancher un débat idéologique
l'adn du parti socialiste ce sont des
courants différents ce sont des prêts et
des positionnements différents
il faut lors des congrès est ce que ce
bilan mitigé dont il parlait c'est pas
effectivement la conséquence de la
primaire de 2011
alors peut-être que on peut en tout cas
penser que c'est le caractère aussi de
françois hollande qui est un homme
effectivement qui est un homme du
consensus on l'a souvent dit et qui a
essayé peut-être de ménager les uns et
les autres sans trancher une position
idéologique claire et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens élection
après élection nous disent la même chose
ils veulent un cap clair le problème
c'est pas de dire il ya des choses bien
à droite il ya des choses bien à gauche
et finalement ce clivage droite gauche
n'existe plus bien sûr que si et encore
plus aujourd'hui avec un françois fillon
en face le clivage droite gauche doit
exister
parions doit fixer un cap clair avec des
positions idéologiques clairs et je
crois qu arnaud montebourg depuis des
années dit la même chose va dans le même
sens du pardon va dans le bon sens est
en capacité aujourd'hui de rassembler
les gauches mode clavequin vous avez
levé les yeux au ciel quand les gens
qu'on a interrogés dans la rue
répétez manuel valls manuel valls manuel
valls pour reprendre le flambeau
pourquoi moi ce que je voudrais déjà
dire c'est que je ne crois pas à la
théorie des gauches irréconciliables
bien au contraire
ce qui est important aujourd'hui pour la
famille de gauche pour notre famille de
gauche c'est de repenser le socialisme
du xxième siècle de rentrer pleinement
dans le 21e siècle il est important
aujourd'hui que l'on ait une ligne que
l'on puisse débattre que l'on puisse
avoir entre nous une ligne à proposer
claire pouvait le parti de saleh se
produit encore des idées bien sûr bien
sûr et après l'ag excusez moi mais on
les voit pas trop et je pense et je
pense que la primaire citoyenne
aujourd'hui qui va avoir lieu au mois de
janvier sera également l'occasion pour
nous de débattre effectivement ça a été
dit il ya plusieurs courants plusieurs
motions au parti socialiste bien modèle
aujourd'hui que nous puissions débattre
ça enfin c'est des voeux pieux presque
hier la belle alliance populaire qu'est
le nom de ce rassemblement qui organise
la primaire il n'y avait pas il n'y
avait pas un candidat canard cac a pris
la parole il y avait finalement peu de
militants il ya des dizaines et des
dizaines de chaises vides
on sent par un élan extraordinaire
autour de ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui
l'annnonce de françois hollande est
évidemment encore très présente dans les
têtes
il est important et je le redis que nous
débattions très rapidement sur quelles
lignes nous avons envie de proposer en
français et l'union doit être
aujourd'hui notre seul objectif
j'invite d'ailleurs très solennellement
l'ensemble des candidats qui se
positionne aujourd'hui en dehors de la
primaire à venir nous rejoindre
d'une part parce qu'un dissident face et
je regarde effectivement francs soit en
face de moi je pense que c'est important
aujourd'hui de réunir les gauches il y a
effectivement un pluralisme à gauche
mais il est important aujourd'hui que
nous puissions débattre en autres
simples pour qu'il ya une chance demain
de battre françois fillon alors mode
claquin vous êtes responsable du parti
socialiste dans le département du
territoire de belfort
l'appel que vous venez de lancer il ya
deux de vos collègues qui l'ont lancé
depuis lundi c'est michel neugnot qui
est patron du ps en côte-d'or et nicolas
baudin dans le doubs michel neugnot que
tous ceux qui se réclament de la gauche
participent à cette primaire nicolas
baudois que jean luc mélenchon emmanuel
macron yannick jadot participent à cette
primaire sinon la présidentielle se
terminera dès le soir du premier tour
pour la gauche
vous êtes d'accord ces ligues majeures
moi je pense en tout cas que on ne peut
pas ne pas participer aux primaires
aujourd'hui les citoyens aujourd'hui
sont pour les primaires on a vu à droite
l'engouement citoyen qui a présidé à
leur primaire je crois qu'aucun candidat
aujourd'hui ne peut se présenter aux
primaires
ce serait un aveu de d'hégémonie de dieu
finalement alors que tous les autres se
confrontent leurs idées confrontent
leurs programmes moi j'arrive et je dis
que je suis le mieux placé sans avoir
débattu mois la position d' emmanuel
macron je ne la comprends pas je pense
que il est en contradiction il n'arrête
pas de parler de la notion de progrès
mais elle ne souhaite pas participer à
cet élan des primaires quelque chose
d'innovant
de novateur qui est plébiscité par par
nos concitoyens
donc je pense qu'il est en totale
contradiction entre cette volonté
d'innovation et en même temps cette
capacité à se mettre en avant
et puis alors en marche emmanuel macron
que ses initiales soit le titre même de
son mouvement
je crois qu'il faut arrêter avec l'homme
providentiel on a besoin de programmes
on a besoin d'un cap on a besoin d'un
projet pour la france et pas d'un homme
président providentiel ni présidentielle
françois patriat emmanuel macron dans le
jdd ce matin passe à l'attaqué enfin il
il en remet une couche qui confirme qu'
il ne sera pas candidat à la primaire il
parle de querelles de clans il refusa de
mars il refuse de débats emmanuel macron
n'est pas dans l'attaqué le mouvement
est dans la bienveillance et emmanuel
n'est jamais dans l'attaqué d'un de
bienveillance hier à la viande est
sûrement fermerait pas dans des
querelles de clans cette primaire c'est
ok corral il est pas dans l'attaqué par
des hans je pense que les primaires j'ai
pas là pour faire un plaidoyer pro domo
je suis là pour expliquer la démarche
les primaires elle n'existe pas dans la
vème république les seuls primaire
institutionnel c'est le premier tôt
c'est le premier tour les primeurs les
primaires telles que nous le propose lui
et moi des premières du parti socialiste
avec des candidats du parti socialiste
dont au cas aujourd'hui on est en
situation de battre de battre françois
fillon aucun mais au cas où les chiffres
du jour aucun ne peut le faire qu'avec
ça va être une primaire d'auxerre vous
aurez des réunionnais à des fins
d'abbadia des intérêts non non pas du
tout j'interromps pas on a trompés tous
tout est un peu le temps de m'expliquer
ce avec quatre candidats ou six ou huit
candidats du parti socialiste pas les
radicaux de gauche pas les verts pas
mélenchon savait donc ça va être une
primaire de congrès on va savoir quelle
est la mission qui va l'emporter pour
diriger le parti socialiste après une
défaite déjà assumé déjà assumé et pour
savoir qui reprendra les cendres du ps
nous ne nous avec emmanuel macron nous
ne voulons pas de cela nous voulons
comme l'a dit françois hollande
je souhaite que les progressistes de
tous bords puissent se réunir pour
sauver la france demain et la relever du
déclin et quand les progressistes ya des
progressistes à droite c'est par ni
droite ni gauche c'est les progressistes
de droite et de gauche ne produisent de
droite et de gauche j'entends bien
puis se retrouver non pas pour
construire un catalogue de la redoute
sur laquelle on s'entendra à la fin de
la primaire socialiste mais pour faire
un véritable projet qui demain change la
donne face à la digitalisation du monde
à la mondialisation de l'économie
alors là problèmes de l'europe et face
aux problèmes de l'environnement
il s'agit de faire un projet non pas un
catalogue le jouais bien je suis au
parti socialiste je connais je connais
le catalogue qu'on fait à chaque fois je
le redoute encore plus aujourd'hui une
partie l'instant je reste ou non mais le
sauf que le premier secrétaire a dit que
à partir du moment où il y aurait un
candidat issu de la primaire ceux qui
soutiennent pas ce candidat seront mis
de côté grec vous j'ai déjà été exclu en
80 donc vous est survenu après on peut
vraiment fils si la f1 d'exclusion
permet un candidat parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le seul recours le seul
recours est d'ailleurs c'est celui qui
est le troisième homme aujourd'hui celui
qui est en tête dans les sondages
si bien qu'on peut pas dire qu'ils ont
pu faire pro sondages je suis d'accord
avec vous mais n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui
celui qui apparaît comme l'homme le plus
capable de faire gagner le camp du
progrès c'est emmanuel macron alors on
va l'attaquer je sais qu'aujourd'hui
nous devenons l'acide pourquoi parce que
nous créions l'espoir que nous
dérangeons c'est très bien on a va
continuer à avancer
où on verrait que la semaine prochaine à
paris samedi prochain et va nous serons
près de 10000 on avance une question
andré tel le phénix le ps survivra grâce
entre autres aux profils bien typés de
monsieur fillon excellents liens
naturels il est vrai malgré le programme
on va dire bien la droite de françois
fillon vous n'avez pas faire l'union
qu'est ce qui se passe mais on va
réussir à faire l'union alors quand
j'entends françois patriat les jantes
les choses ou quand même tout frais je
veux nous demander de faire les choses
comme on dit chez nous vous mettez un
petit peu la charrue avant les boeufs
comme on dit dans le morvan est à dire
que à six mois d'une présidentielle
c'est trop tôt non faire le nom ça c'est
le jeu qu'à jouer françois hollande en
mettant la primaire aussi tard c'est lui
qui a joué le timing et le tempo
maintenant le rassemblement il est
possible autour des gauches et je crois
une fois de plus que c'est autour de
cette notion de rassemblement des
gauches que l'on pourra gagner est
effectivement gagné contre un programme
qui est clairement un programme
d'austérité un programme libéral un
programme conservateur de la droite il
faut naturellement en face un candidat
ou une candidate de gauche et de gauche
assumer et non pas quelqu'un qui nous
dit
finalement je sais pas trop où j'habite
il faut une ligne claire et une ligne de
gauche mode clasquin la gauche et le
parti socialiste en particulier
saft il encore où ils habitent oui
indéniablement oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons une grave
crise institutionnelle une grave crise
démocratique je pense que tout le monde
s'accorde à le dire
la question est de savoir comment l'on
arrive à proposer des solutions pour
s'en sortir
pour redonner confiance dans la classe
politique pour redonner confiance dans
l'action publique vous redonner
confiance dans l'avenir tout simplement
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui cette idée
que les gauches doivent s'unir et je le
redis au sein la primaire citoyenne est
évidemment un objectif premier pour
arriver effectivement à reconquérir
l'électorat alors il faut rassembler
dites-vous jean christophe cambadélis
disait en début de semaine la décision
du président de la république inspire le
respect et nous oblige
et pourtant il y a quelques semaines
quand jean christophe cambadélis a
présenté les modalités de la primaire je
vous propose d'écouter ce qu'ils
disaient c'est très intéressant et on se
dit que le rassemblement c'est quand
même pas gagné écouter jean christophe
cambadélis c'était le 2 octobre
nous appelons l'ensemble des citoyens de
gauche et des écologistes qui ne
participent pas à la primaire des
écologistes ou à l'orientation
2 jean luc mélenchon voire du parti
communiste de participer à cette
primaire
[Musique]
maud clavequin une primaire qui
rassemblait alors sans les écologistes
qui ont participé à la primaire des
écologistes sans les communistes et sans
les partisans de jean-luc mélenchon
le rassemblement qui commence par
exclure est ce que c'est une bonne idée
mais je pense que nous devons travailler
jusqu'au dernier moment a rassemblé
l'ensemble des partenaires de gauche au
sein de cette primaire cela c'est parce
que fait le patron du parti socialiste
quand il dit je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est évidemment tellement
importante et est l'enjeu de battre le
programme ultra conservateur et
ultralibéral que nous propose françois
fillon ou marine le pen parce qu'on en
parle plus beaucoup en ce moment mais il
faut quand même le dire il est
aujourd'hui en embuscade et cet enjeu là
d'éviter un front national fort à la
présidentielle passe évidemment par ce
travail d' union des gauches je pense
que nous pouvons y arriver nous devons y
arriver il en va de notre responsabilité
collective
si demain nous ne voulons pas que le
pays retombe dans les travers
ultralibéraux et ultraconservateurs
céline maglica on parle d' union des
gauches
si votre candidat ne gagne pas
la primaire est ce que vous soutiendrez
un candidat par exemple issu du
gouvernement je pense à manuel valls
mais il ya peut-être d'autres ministres
qui se présenteront est-ce que l'union
se fera alors moi j'appartiens à un
parti et je suis fidèle à mon parti si
effectivement un candidat autre
qu'arnaud montebourg est désigné lors
des primaires et bien je soutiendrai sa
candidature parce que moi je ne vous
convient pas eh bien j'espère justement
qu'on sera en capacité encore d'influer
sur le programme parce qu'au-delà des
hommes on est en train de parler de nom
avec des hommes
mais ce qui importe quelles sont les
idées qui sont dernier derrière et moi
simplement ce que je dis depuis des
années ça fait 15 ans que je soutiens
les idées d'arnaud montebourg c'est
qu'il faut profondément changé repenser
la politique il faut un statut de l'élu
il faut repenser notre manière il faut
changer de logiciel vraiment parce
qu'aujourd'hui on retourne dans des
débats qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
les gens attendent autre chose de la
politique les gens attendent de nous que
nous soyons responsables être un élu et
un responsable politique c'est un
engagement sur un temps donné
et une fois qu'on a exercé sa mission eh
bien on retourne dans la vie civile je
crois qu'on a besoin de réaffirmer sa et
les gens nous ferons à nouveau confiance
et referont confiance en la politique
si on se met dans cet esprit
collaboratif collectif et donc je
soutiendrai celui ou celle qui sortira
des primaires
en espérant que nous allions vers ce
renouvellement de la vie politique
françois patriat est ce que vous êtes
prêts dans le camp d'emmanuel macron à
assumer un éventuel deuxième tour
françois fillon marine le pen parce que
c'est le reproche qu'on vous fera
forcément mais justement ne renversez
pas les choses vous savez je renverse
donne une question j'ai vu une anecdote
j'ai été interrogé par un de vos
confrères homogène disait est ce que est
ce que françois est ce que emmanuel
macron osera se présenterait contre
françois hollande qui mèneront vers
c'est pas la chose est ce que françois
hollande osera se présenter contre
emmanuel macron on en est là aujourd'hui
il était sur emmanuel main contenant la
police à hilla t il a été contraint et
forcé par ses propres amis de ne pas se
présenter
qu'importe c'est justement aujourd'hui
s'écarter mais aujourd'hui tous les
candidats du ps
aucun d'été lisible aujourd'hui pour le
deuxième tour aucun le seul qui compte
aujourd'hui 10 à 17 dans les sondages
ulrich
17 qui peut éventuellement rattraper
dans les sacs mois de campagne on change
dans la politique j'aime bien ce que dit
céline un instant il dit repenser la
politique
le seul qui repenser la politique
aujourd'hui au-delà des mesures
anecdotique sur le statut de l'élu passe
à repenser la politique c'est mobiliser
les énergies
c'est redonner le pouvoir aux citoyens
c'est croire à la liberté c'est croire
en la valeur travail c'est ça la
politique aujourd'hui le seul qui le
pensent et emmanuel macron non quand je
pense ne verse que le seul recours
aujourd'hui pour éviter je ne me résous
pas je ne me résous pas aller voter au
deuxième tour entre françois fillon et
marine le pen
je pense qu'il y a non pas une
alternance telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui le une alternative
cette alternative crédible elle est
incarnée par un jeune homme jeune
nouveaux tirs dont le charisme et réels
qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas plu aux
français mais qui apporte un souffle
nouveau dans la politique je pense que
c'est pour lui que le jour dit le
mobiliser au delà des primeurs partie du
parti socialiste qui seront anecdotiques
à la fin de ce débat présidentiel
anecdotique mode cloud
je ne pense pas que ces primaires seront
anecdotiques bien au contraire
je le redis le débat est important je
partage l'idée j'ai été signataires il
ya peu d'une tribune qui promeut le
renouveau et le renouveau ce n'est pas
seulement des figures nouvelles c'est
des idées nouvelles et des lignes
nouvelles et la primaire va permettre ce
débat là il faut impérativement que la
primaire permet de ce déballage des
nouvelles que l'on aimé néo-marxiste
d'il ya 40 ans mais je pense
qu'effectivement le socialisme doit
comprendre que nous ne sommes plus
aujourd'hui dans les mêmes
problématiques que nous avons connu il
ya plus d'un siècle maintenant il y à
des révolutions que nous devons
impérativement intégrer la révolution
numérique
la révolution écologique la révolution
économique et sas le devoir de les voter
manuellement le débat de la primaire le
permettra assurément et je n'en doute
pas je reviens à la question de départ
le renouveau le chaos on en est là le ps
peut imploser la dans six mois céline
maglica sais c'est un risque que vous
prenez en compte c'est un risque depuis
depuis quelques mois déjà on voit bien
que le parti socialiste depuis plusieurs
mois peut exploser peut imploser
parce que c'est une vieille machine
hocine qui a besoin d'évolution et nous
le disons depuis un petit moment
moi ce que je trouve sain et rassurant
aujourd'hui c'est de voir que les
citoyens sont en train de se de se
ressaisir de ses outils politiques dont
nous avons besoin
je trouve ça est rassurant de voir que
effectivement la politique elle est ce
qu'on en fait et non pas ce qu on en
subit
c'est ce que les citoyens n'arrête pas
de nous dire et je crois que le parti
socialiste s'il évolue dans le bon sens
s'il écoute ce que les citoyens disent
il peut effectivement renaître et
retrouver de beaux jours devant lui
r- proposer des idées qui soit celle du
xxième siècle qu'ils soient ancrés dans
le réel et qui comme disait comme disait
jaurès
aya l'idéal dans en dix minutes
francis letellier reçoit jean luc
mélenchon candidat lui aussi est ce que
vous avez un message pour lui françois
patriat si vous l'aviez en face de vous
quelqu'un la pole du tout alors je vous
vois mon cher jean luc j'apprécie total
en jeu mais la seule question c'est
comment penses-tu le défendre les plus
démunis
avec aujourd'hui des idées qui date de
près de 50 en un mot pour jean luc
mélenchon votre placard jean lui que je
pense que vous avez toute votre place au
sein de la primaire citoyenne venez
débattre avec l'ensemble dé gauche
céline céline maglica pardon alors moi
comme j'ai un esprit rebelle comme lui
je l'appellerai camarades et je le
tutoie ray je lui dirai jean luc
mélenchon au 21e siècle il faut
participer aux primaires si on veut être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
sinon on n'est pas dans sa chambre mais
rosicky terroir à la primaire imaginez
de gaulle et ses hangars vides et on en
parlera évidemment merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci eric sicaud aussi pour la
préparation dans un instant jean
christophe gallais 10 pour l'information
en franche-comté informations aussi en
bourgogne
et puis en suisse dont francis letellier
avec jean luc mélenchon
profitez bien de votre dimanche après
midi